so this was your first time at san diego
comic con
i don't even know if it was your first
comic-con um what was it like
i think second
second ever san diego san diego
comic-con and i went to one in new york
once for press that was it so this was
your first san diego comic-con full one
yeah yeah so i went once as a spectator
like 20 years ago oh it's a lot yeah
it's a lot different now um
what
looking back what was it like for you as
like a first timer pretty crazy it was
cool
it was cool like you know it's always
when you're doing press and it's just a
red carpet or if it's just an interview
it's one thing but when you feel 10 000
people cheering and yelling and that's
cool man i always liked live shows back
when i was a stunt performer we did a
couple of and they're always great uh
jumping into why i get to talk to you um
so what was it about how did you
actually get involved in in day shift
um funny enough uh it was i think it was
even before you have to check with jj
put the director uh but it was a little
before we even started on on john lick
three parabellum jj had found a screen
like he was toying with the idea of
directing he'd already been a quite
established second unit guy
and
again i there are probably some people
in the sun industry that see myself or
dave leach or some of the walls you know
and some of the other guys that direct
and they go i'll be a director too and
then there's just guys that happen to be
performing sunset actually really want
to direct
um i think jg is one of those guys just
you know has always had the inkling to
try something but was looking for like
just much like dave leitch myself you're
looking for the right one that fits
instead of being so eager to direct and
take anything you want the one that you
think you can knock out of the park
so jj had mentioned that he had found
the script that kind of had hints of
potential in it
and
you know i vaguely remember it and cut
to
literally almost three years later he's
like look i you know i really want to do
this now i've kind of decided what where
i want my life to go i want to try
directing i think this is the one would
you mind taking a look at it i'm like
okay i vaguely remember let's let's
check it out again
read it
did note i'm like okay
it's it's a hidden world it's kind of
like a john wick
spin-off just with vampires it's got a
hidden world but it's a little quirkier
you know i get it it was kind of fun
and i was like okay well i get this it
has some problems with plot and some
character stuff like how i was like come
in give me your pitch
and you think because i've known jj for
almost 30 something years so we have a
short hand to say at least like any good
friend would
so
you could have the individual that comes
in and talks to you like a friend like
yo bro come on do me aside let's do this
jj came in quite the opposite he came in
like he was pitching a major studio came
in with vision boards came in with his
his lookbook
and goes
boom and he he threw the he pitched it
like he was pitching for his life like
details characters down the music down
what he wanted all the different ways
you could spin it you know an hour later
i'm like okay stop
i'm in what do we got to do
i'm in and uh you know we then we had
the talk it's like okay if we do this
we're not after what i've just heard
we're not gonna try and just
softball this one in and just try to get
it made we're are you good i'm gonna
throw the full weight of us being we're
gonna we're gonna do this
and even then i don't think he got like
no we're we're gonna make a big we're
going to do this like i get it this is
worth it we're good
and that's how i got attached and i said
look i'm i'm going to attach 87-11 we're
going to go big we're going we're going
to go and he's just like
like i think after we decided um i think
it was only a couple weeks
we had been doing some other dealings
with some of the other studios and we're
like
okay we're gonna bring this to lionsgate
that's weird first look deal and then
right off the bat i know i already know
somebody at netflix would be interested
in this
um we went to two or three other studios
all within two three like literally this
all happened in 48 hours we did our
pitch rounds um
you know we had given the the right
amount of time to the people that were
supposed to but like as soon as the
clock ticked i mean literally to the
minute netflix is on the phone gun we're
in we want it done
i'm like oh
oh okay great and we're in and then
within two more weeks our casting list
had been done and jamie fong had kept
appearing on people both we were
interested in jj was very favorable for
and people that netflix liked to work
with and
it just kept hit every time we went down
lit he kept hitting you in the face like
jamie foxx and you just
he's talented he can sing you dance he's
a stand-up comedian but he can play real
heartfelt roles he's empathetic he's
physical and you're just like i would
buy that guy being a dad i would buy
that guy being a fish out of water i
would buy that guy being an action star
like it just kept
you couldn't you couldn't get it out of
your head once it was in
and jj just was all on board and
actually jj went no i'm good this is guy
do you want to talk up no this is this
is it and then we built the cast around
jamie and
obviously david franco is
you know
i don't know what to say other than he's
hilarious i mean he really he's a good
human he's a hard worker and he's funny
and then you throw in snoop dogg and the
rest of the cast i think it's pretty
impressive
i mean it it's one of the fastest shows
we've ever put together because one you
read it you get it it's fun
it's like you know if i gave you the
pitch sign it's generally vampires but
it's a little lighter in tone and you
get to shoot a lot of vampires in the
face you're like okay
you know and then jj spun it enough to
be like this west coast
uh very indigenous la version of the
story which you know we can all relate
to and uh you know again
he came at it from such a strategic way
of knowing how to put his money where
his mouth is both for comedy and for
action and it's something i didn't you
know john wick has a heavier tone so it
was fun to go do something where we can
just have a lot more fun what's funny is
um i was talking to jj yesterday and i
was telling him like it's you it's easy
to sell john wick with vampires but it's
not john wick with vampires the way the
thing is like there's a like the you
know the union and like the world but
like everything else is not john wick at
all
that's why it was an easy pitch line but
to nail
you know comedy i still think is the
hardest thing out there and that's um to
nail that tone takes a little bit of in
it takes it you got to know where you're
going you need to go you need the vision
so i think that's what he had that
opening fight sequence in this movie
with the grandma vampire is fantastic
that's our that's my favorite sequence
in the whole movie by far yeah it's i
mean if you if you first of all it's
important to start the movie off with
something cool to pull people in but
this is a very well staged and shot
sequence that uses old school filmmaking
with practical can you sort of talk
about the sequence sure jj like we we
knew we weren't going to have a ton of
cash
we knew jj's first movie you have to
make you have to make a statement you
have to do something tricky jj's from
the same generation that me dave and
everybody else from we're from the sled
of hand generation as we call it like we
want to use we have nothing
we have no
antagonistic intent towards vfx it's
just how you use them we don't want you
to we don't want to give away anything
we don't want you know it's a prosthetic
we want you know it's a wire gag we
don't want you we just don't want you to
know we wanted to keep the magic in
filmmaking
he's like okay well i want to do all
these great things and i'm like okay
what's things like
look uh i'm going to use contortionists
for the vampires i'm gonna make a move
differently so we don't just say okay
it's gonna be an actor next you know
it's a digi double or a digital double
just run around doing stuff like you
know our goal has always been in our
whole little cook is
uh
get great people they do great things
you get amazing people they'll do
amazing things
sorry a lot of dogs
how many dogs how many dogs do you have
between me and my girlfriend we have
four right now
how's the kennel
okay thank you
um
you know so again the sleight of hand
thing is is a big deal for us it's
how do we do cool stuff with real people
and jj's answer was let's get cool and
amazing people i'm like yeah fair enough
uh so instead of just reaching out to
the
uh i guess
popular stunt community he went to
cirque du soleil he took a trip visited
some of the different training
found i think it was about a dozen great
contortionists and put him in vampire
makeup and made him bend and flip
backwards and we're like yeah fair
enough haven't seen that one yet cool
and that's how we maximize our time now
one of the things about the film is that
uh he had i believe 42 days to shoot the
film which is not a lot of time uh can
you in in action movie time though yeah
exactly so i mean that's the thing i
think he really it's all up there in
terms of the screen but another thing
that i really enjoyed is that um i don't
want to give anything away but the
script takes a
it does some things in the second or
beginning of the third act that i didn't
see coming which is always nice
i mean there are certain directors out
there that get the script they lock it
like do not [ __ ] with script and you're
like
totally get that and i i'm like that
with certain ways too but like
the script wasn't completely written for
jamie or david or for the environment
stuff or the locations that we
necessarily use because that's an
organic process when you have a lot of
money to go and if you're not building
every set if you're not you know doing a
digital environment every time like some
studios can you gotta roll the punches a
little bit and that evolves
um both cast financially logistically so
if you look at it from a cast point
it's a lead up right like the first week
it was just jamie
with the old lady that's the first thing
jj shot it wasn't till almost like two
weeks later did david start and they
start their scenes and then when they
start their scene like once we had done
the um
uh
the the pawn shop
and you see the emotional interaction
between them and the comedy interaction
you're like ah
we're doing now like and you find that
and now they start morphing their
relationship okay now we got to keep up
and you're constantly tweaking the
scenes because you want the big punch
line or you see how the dynamic is okay
that's now we didn't do enough we got to
do our homework more and just let jane
drift like david riff like on any good
comedian or a good performer you got to
give him a little leash to to try things
you got to make him feel safe and i
think between jj's
experience on okay we're going with it
we have the best plan but we're also
organic and liquid to change we're going
to make it better not beholden to any
one thing and you got two performers
that love to riff and change
it organically grows so you have to roll
that into the storyline right so you get
to the the second act which we had which
was kind of one way and then we're like
no we like the relationship we're gonna
really fall back on that and then the
plot starts twisting a little bit for
that you're like okay can can david and
jamie pull off what what's going to
happen in the flip and you're like yep
un did never never doubted david's
ability to make that switch so
uh what are you actually most looking
forward to audiences seeing in the film
again i hate to get to to existential
but like look i've known jj for
30-something years we've come up with
stuntmen together we've come up like
that um due to a career path you know
i've been directing for the last nine
and a half 10 years now first unit with
all the wicks
and the growth spurt you have in your
life is like okay you think you're
really prepared when you direct your
first move you realize how dumb you
really were and then you get a little
cocky and then you do your second when
you're like yeah i was even dumber than
the first one
so
it's more for me to answer your
questions about the experience honestly
jj hasn't had an opening night yet and i
have and the first time you you walk out
there to the audience and you're sitting
and you're watching it and you hear
people actually clap for the [ __ ] that
you've done and all the pain and
suffering and all the angst and all the
stuff because even as grown men you're
still like
wow that's it kind of chokes you up a
little bit when you realize you've done
something that people like and there's
an ego boost but it's also emotional
it's a catharsis and all that pain and
suffering and fighting and stuff goes i
want to sit right next to him and look
at his face when everybody goes out it
was pretty funny um that's what i'm the
first time we watch it together with an
audience i'm probably just going to
stare at him
this is a joke w gets but in the movie
honestly i'm all for the you know as
much as i love everything i'm all in for
the old lady fight i love grandma i
think that's
that's the one i want i get into right
when i was watching the film that
sequence specifically i'm like oh [ __ ]
this is really well done you know this
is just a really cool sequence um
uh before i move on to something else
you've obviously worked with many
producers
what did you want to do because i
believe this is your first time
producing a movie like this yeah as a
full person yeah yeah what did you want
what did you take away from the
producers you've worked with to make
sure that you are like the best possible
producer that you can be
well uh
look because most producers haven't
directed before
you know it's very easy to slide into uh
those directors i don't know you know
crazy guy like they just need to like
it'll be fine you just cut it it'll all
work out okay that that's kind of
[ __ ]
and then i've been the director that
looks at the bruce like they'll never
[ __ ] understand they don't understand
my genius they don't see my vision right
so i think the unique thing about a
producer director especially in
properties like this that's
so
close to the genre dj is doing is like
look you gotta see both sides you gotta
step in both shoes you gotta be careful
what you say but you have to ride the
wave man like i gotta be produced in one
minute and then i gotta be directed the
next minute the advantage i have i speak
both languages
so you know when when you see crazy
director guy wig it out over what seems
like a miniscule little thing there's
something else behind that it's not
about getting the one shot it's the
thread it's the emotions all the time
it's like in his head he sees it as the
keystone to the scene
some producers look at well wait
okay relax it's not about the 10 grand
and it's not about it look in our
business there is a constant
um
constant tension between creative and
commerce it's
you know you can't be kooky artist guy
drive around your ferrari and shoot all
over the world if you don't make money
there's you know they're letting us do
they're letting the patients have the
keys to the asylum because we make
like that's the gig right so you can be
kooky creative all you want but you have
to at least at some level pay attention
to that and the other side is like look
as a producer you have to understand
like [ __ ] the money let's make something
[ __ ] cool for the fans let's make
something we want to like there's always
that tension right
the trick is always and it's never the
same day today you got to find that
balance you got to talk to both sides so
i guess you got to hold tight
and talk him through the unseen stuff
that he hasn't had yet like i got to
talk to jj like look man i gotta be your
guide up the mountain you gotta climb
the mountain but i can help tell you
where not to step maybe not where to
step but where not to step and as far as
the producers in the studio goes like
look
i got him i get it give him the rope or
hey this is where we need to force them
into the box it would be twice as
creative trust me this guy's going to
pull it out
so i wish i could tell you there's some
forum formula or algorithm to talk to
either side but there's really not at
the end of the day steve it's about
people and if you understand what people
want or what their focus is
you can help
guide the other side through that it's
it's you know it from as far as for
myself when i'm a director i just want
to know that you're sweating the same
[ __ ] on sweat so if it's keeping me up
at night i just want my producers to say
hey man it's [ __ ] keeping me up too
they may not mean it but that makes me
feel like okay i'm not alone and i think
that's a big thing
and you also want to make studio feel
like look we haven't let
you know the crazy guys to the key to
the gun locker you know like
you got to make both sides feel safe